angry mob gathered in downtown Tehran
yesterday chanting slogans attacking the
United States protester stolen American
flag from a nearby vehicle and set it on
fire
America was never great they screamed
terrifying but hold on a sec that
actually didn't happen in Iran much as
it seems like it it happened in Los
Angeles in our country the one they say
was never great the screaming stealing
flag burning mob was there to express
their love and support for congressman
Maxine Waters waters had inspired them
with the rhetoric like this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
meanwhile elsewhere in Los Angeles a
newly opened coffee shop was attacked by
masked protesters who hurled feces at
the building they said the owner of the
building supports Donald Trump's
immigration policies well as it happens
the owner is himself an immigrant
I'm confused he said but it didn't
matter on the left the penalty for
Thought crime is Swift and certain if
nonsensical for disagreeing with the mob
on immigration the immigrant owner is
not allowed to make a living those are
the rules
well this lunacy did not come out of the
blue it has been brewing for quite some
time
[Applause]
well we first saw this brand of
extremism on college campuses where
student activists demonstrated against
new ideas they didn't understand or
against any kind of dissent from the
narrow orthodoxy of the campus left over
time though their protests became
physical and then dangerous windows
smashed fires set people beaten and
threatened with death in the past few
months scenes like that have moved off
campus into our world the left began
threatening Trump administration
officials who dared to appear in public
kicking them out of restaurants and
screaming at them on the street now
they're targeting private citizens who
might be sympathetic to the
administration won't open a small
business well you can't do that unless
you voice this week's progressive dogmas
that's a lesson corporate America
learned years ago and as applied ever
since it is of course at the very
opposite of freedom the fall elections
are less than four months from today
tempers will rise even higher than they
are now that is guaranteed something
awful could easily happen now right now
is the time for progressive leaders to
douse the fires that they set to calm
their inflamed supporters it is vital
they do that and yet they're doing the
opposite now they're telling their
followers that the President of the
United States is a Russian spy a traitor
the penalty for treason is death
traitors of course must be overthrown
the mob screams wild with rage Democrats
are banking that that rage will get
their voters to the polls in November
and they may be right it may it may also
destroy the country